[Music]
all right so this is apple's hot new
laptop for 2022 and the first with the
new second generation of apple silicon
inside we have a new macbook air and
it's redesigned it's pretty sweet we got
this announcement at wwdc on stage a
couple days ago and i did get to spend
some actual hands-on time with the new
laptop which is what this video is and
after the half hour so i actually got to
spend with it i was left with
one main thought and one new question
the thought about the color and the
question
about the lineup so first of all i love
the design refresh apple's new laptop
design language as we've seen from the
previous macbook pros is very squared
off so this macbook air is no longer a
wedge shape it's very much rectangular
with the sharper edges but it's still an
air it's still razor thin 11.3
millimeters total z height less than
half an inch and 2.7 pounds it kind of
to me looks like two ipads sandwiched
together basically still all metal still
really well balanced and easy to hold
definitely earns the air name right so
on the right side there's a headphone
jack with the new high impedance
headphone support and on the left
there's two thunderbolt ports and they
added magsafe and it'll actually come
with a color matched magsafe cable which
is new and it's a really nice touch so
there's four new colors of this laptop
silver space gray then starlight and
midnight so each magsafe cable matches
the color of the laptop you plug it into
the side it looks pretty seamless i just
love them bringing back magsafe here and
then with magsafe they also added fast
charging up to 67 watts with an optional
power brick that's good for adding 50
charge in half an hour which is pretty
good apple also showed us on stage there
was this slide of a dual usb type c
charger which looks pretty sweet just a
heads up though that one is not 67 watts
that's not the super fast charging that
is 35 watts i got to actually hold it
and read that on the back of the brick
so you can get either the fast charger
or dual usb c charger anyway this laptop
also gets a new quad speaker setup sort
of those tucked in the hinge underneath
the display which is kind of cool and a
new triple mic array with beam forming
audio i i can't test that stuff in the
limited hands on time i have with it in
a huge echoey steve jobs theater so
definitely get subscribed to see the
review of that and all the other stuff i
get to test when i actually get my hands
on one but i think really the biggest
change that i'm gonna notice with this
new laptop is at the front it's the
display so in basically the same
footprint as the last macbook air they
thinned out the bezels all the way
around making room for a slightly bigger
13.6 inch display which is now also
brighter at 500 nits basically matching
the 13-inch macbook pro and of course it
now has the notch with the new 1080p
webcam up there also this is again part
of the new apple pro aesthetic that
honestly we're already getting used to
as dorky as it looks when you just stare
at it but anyway you also have a full
height function row up at the top of the
magic keyboard with touch id in the
corner backlit keys the whole deal i
mentioned in the last video midnight
this this new dark color
might not be the way to go i and i say
that reluctantly because we love a good
matte black but as you may know from the
name of the color it's actually the same
as the apple watch series 7. so it's not
quite black it's slightly blue as
hopefully you can tell from my clips but
also in my very very limited time
playing with it uh it picks up a lot of
fingerprints a lot and it was kind of
hard to clean off so in my time handling
it getting fingerprints all over the
thing and getting kind of annoyed with
trying to clean them off
it made me lean way more towards like
just safe space gray or maybe silver
which would never show those
fingerprints i don't know maybe maybe
you just get a dbrand icon skin slap it
on the back and never worry about it
maybe you just don't care about the
fingerprints and you just deal with it
i'm just saying just putting it out
there can't say i didn't warn you but
the new m2 chip inside is of course
super important and this is what's gonna
make this ultra thin and light laptop
actually perform and be very very
impressive again gonna do some testing
and using it but apple's promising some
broad things like roughly 20 percent
better cpu performance than m1 and 30 to
35 better gpu performance which is a
pretty big jump over the m1 which is
already very capable uh all within the
same
18 hours of video playback really good
battery life so it's impressive there's
more memory bandwidth up to 100
gigabytes per second more maximum system
memory at 24 gigs but it's worth
remembering this is still very much the
baseline chip right the m1 pro and the
m1 ultra chips are definitely still
higher end chips and we can expect new
generations of i guess an m2 pro and an
m2 ultra at some point but yeah this m2
is targeted for
baseline everyday computing and then
occasional maybe some more demanding
stuff it can handle stuff like video
editing light gaming stuff you want to
throw at it once in a while but here's
where it gets interesting it is more
expensive so i had no problem
recommending the m1 macbook air at 9.99
right this is now like two years or so
later this m2 macbook air starts at
11.99 so 1200 laptop it's a little more
pricey but they're keeping the
two-year-old m1 macbook air with the old
design in the lineup still at 9.99 so
now you know at this price it's it's not
like a instant recommendation for me and
having a two-year-old laptop not drop in
price is also a little
interesting but to me the weirdest part
of this whole announcement of this
lineup is the one other machine that
they put this new m2 chip in is the m2
macbook pro and this one got absolutely
no redesign at all it is the exact same
body and display and outside as the m1
13-inch macbook pro they just bumped a
new m2 chip inside and so that machine
will start at 12.99
and i just want to just talk about that
for a quick second like i actually feel
like you could make an argument that the
m2 air which is cheaper is actually a
better computer for
most people for 90 something percent of
people you should probably just get the
air look at this chart i expect a new m2
macbook air and m2 macbook pro to cost
the same amount with the same specs
14.99 right at this price though the air
is thinner and lighter has the new
better design has a larger display has
touch id with a real function row which
is i think better than a touch bar it
has magsafe with the color matching
cable it has fast charging that the pro
doesn't have it has a much better webcam
it has new speakers and microphones and
it literally has more ports than the pro
so the only advantage to the pro would
be pairing the m2 chip with a fan so the
active cooling system can get you some
extra performance out of sustained
workloads like long renders and gaming i
guess
and then the slightly longer battery
life from the bigger laptop having a
physically larger battery but if you're
already a person that's thinking about
performance for sustained workloads
and things like ports you're already
going to be looking towards the m1 pro
macbook pro the 14 inch so it's just
kind of a weird sliver of people that i
don't think are gonna actually get very
many m2 macbook pros just my thoughts on
that real quick anyway uh that's pretty
much it the air is a really good machine
the one weird quirk about it that i
noticed is it still only supports one
external display even though it has two
ports now still only one up to 6k
external display but is a good this is a
good machine it's fun to hold and use
and carry around and it makes a
perfectly reasonable computer in a
vacuum the m2 macbook pro
look like a pretty bad deal either way
i'm for sure gonna get my hands on and
test this thing let me know in the
comments which color you think i should
get i'm considering midnight right but
we've seen the fingerprints so i i'm
leaning maybe starlight instead or space
gray anything but silver i don't know
let me know in the comments okay that's
been it thanks for watching catch you
guys in the next one
peace